Speaker 1: A bunch of you sent me articles
about this next story.
And it shouldn't come as a surprise, but it
should be extraordinarily alarming because
of what it means.
The accounting firm, which has represented
Trump's business for a decade, is now saying,
We can't trust, you can't trust I me David
Pakman.
I can't trust the financial accounting records
that they put together for the last decade
because they may be based on underlying fraudulent
information.
And the accounting firm has abandoned Trump
and says they will no longer represent Trump's
business.
This is unbelievable.
A Yahoo News, NBC News reporting Trump Organization's
accounting firms says.
Accounting firm says it can no longer vouch
for financial statements from the company.
This is a major story, and it is not getting
the attention it deserves.
The accounting firm Mazars USA said a decade's
worth of financial statements from the Trump
Organization can no longer be viewed as reliable.
According to a letter made public Monday by
New York Attorney General Letitia James as
part of her civil probe into Trump's company,
Mazars also said it will no longer work with
the Trump Organization, meaning the company
may have to get new financial statements that
could complicate its ability to secure loans.
In a Feb. nine letter from Mazars Group General
Counsel William Kelly to the Trump Organization's
chief legal officer, the auditing firm said
its work from 2011 to 2020 quote should not
be relied upon.
In the world of corporate accounting, this
is like a groundbreaking statement of there's
some really bad stuff going on here and we
meaning the accounting firm want to try to
get the hell out from under what might be
coming in our direction.
They also added, We write to advise that the
statements of financial condition for Donald
J. Trump for the years ending June 30th, 2011
to June 30th, 2020, that's fiscal years should
no longer be relied upon.
And you should inform any recipients thereof
currently relying upon one or more of those
documents that those documents should not
be relied upon.
Understand that that is a signal to all of
the lenders that have given Trump money on
the basis of these financial statements.
They they're being told you made financial
decisions about the Trump Organization's credit
worthiness on the basis of account of account
accounting documents that we, the accounting
firm, are telling you cannot be relied upon.
Here's a copy of the letter sent out.
Dear Alan, this is to Alan Garten, the chief
legal officer of the Trump Organization and
from the accounting firm Dear Alan.
It's like a Dear John letter.
We write to advise that the statement a financial
condition for Donald J. Trump from 2011 to
2020, should no longer be relied upon, and
you should inform recipients relying on those
not to.
We have come to this conclusion.
This is the best part.
We have come to this conclusion, based in
part upon the filings made by the New York
Attorney General on January 18th, 2020, to
our own investigation and information received
from internal and external sources.
They are saying in part, the investigation
being carried out by Letitia James of New
York has brought to their attention the corruption
and alleged fraud potential fraud.
I want to be careful with how I say that committed
by the Trump Organization and we already know
what this relates to, this mostly seems to
relate to the valuation of assets.
What Michael Cohen and others have told us
the Trump Organization would regularly do
is you take a building.
Let's say we agree that in the real world,
the building is worth $20 million.
When it comes to assessment for tax purposes,
the Trump Organization would say, Look at
this crappy building.
It's not worth 20 million, it's worth $10
million.
So tax us on the $10 million valuation and
they would submit documents supporting that.
That's what it's worth.
On the other hand, when the Trump Organization
wanted to get a loan using that same building
as collateral, they would say, wasn't this
building's not worth 10 million?
This building's not worth 20 million.
This building's worth $40 million.
And so you can give us, you know, if it's
an 80 percent loan to value or whatever the
case is, you can give us a loan on the basis
that the collateral we're offering you is
worth 30 or $40 million rather than 20.
And that would encourage a lender to say we
can give them 28 million bucks because if
they default, we take the building and we
sell the building for 30 or 40 when the building
is only worth 10 or 20, giving a $28 million
loan with that building as collateral obviously
is not a good idea for the lender, so that's
the gist of what has been done.
Other notes from the letter due in part to
our decision regarding the financial statements,
as well as the totality of the circumstances,
we have reached the point such that there
is a non-waiver ball conflict of interest
with the Trump Organization.
As a result, we are not able to provide any
new work product to the Trump Organization.
This is an example of rats abandoning a sinking
ship and its crimes all the way down, and
consider that Trump was elected partially
on the basis that he was a really successful
entrepreneur.
And then we found out, well, he's had a bunch
of business bankruptcies, but he said that
was him just using the tax code to his advantage.
This additional thing suggests that even the
degree to which his business was successful
was based upon accounting distortions, or
at least potentially on that basis.
And when I hear you can't trust these accounting
documents and we're not working for you anymore,
what I hear is we committed fraud for the
boss and we're going to get caught and we're
doing what we can to wash our hands of him.
And I think anybody who who knows anything
about Trump knows that cutting corners is
sort of the name of the game.
It's the status quo and people continue to
love the guy and defend the guy.
But this is not looking good at all in terms
of this investigation into the Trump Organization.
Will it ever hit Trump?
I still don't think so.
And I know many of you get mad when I say
that.
But.
I don't think so.
Let me know if you have a different view on
that particular piece.